y lo que bueno esto esto es algo que sé
de lo que se ha especulado bastante en
primer lugar será interesante ver cómo
es esa partida de dan otro de la casa
blanca y no sólo no sólo lo mencionó tal
vez por lo mediático que será el día que
dan otras algas sino porque ahora
empieza el trabajo más difícil es decir
tenemos la idea de que pueden ganar pero
también hay un importante trabajo de
transición y para eso se requiere la
voluntad del gobierno de turno
eso es ese proceso de transición es el
que permite que un nuevo presidente
entre sabiendo qué hacer entre sabiendo
cuál es la agenda cuáles son los actores
es la que permite que ese nuevo
presidente pueda confirmar lo por medio
el proceso de confirmación en el senado
a su nuevo equipo para no dejar a eeuu
vulnerable bueno eso es una cosa ahora
la pregunta es qué va a pasar con trump
el 20 de enero hay una visión un poco
más graciosa más optimista y es claro
acá trump creando por ejemplo su propio
su propio medio
y camps ha estado criticando los medios
no sólo los tradicionales sino también
hasta foxnews que precisamente fue el
primer medio en anunciar que bailar
había ganado arizona pero también hay
una vez una visión un poco más oscura y
eso es que trampa posiblemente actúe
como un presidente de por vida no un
presidente de por vida para sus
simpatizantes